acting is a kind of transient thing you
meet people then you don't but one of
the lovely things we come out of these
films is your friendship with Ian
McKellen but you must have known Ian
McKellen before the films oh yes since I
was a teenager he's two years older than
me he said something the other day
really along with what he was just said
one of the nicest things ever
he said yeah Patrick Stewart and I I
really feel that last I have a brother
that's torille he might have said father
you are you I've kind of a theory about
the way he speaks the way in McKellen
speaks what we did an animated movie
together as well as these you did yeah
it was called flushed away I really love
my son often says why was there no
sequel to that and I said cuz I've lost
a lot of money but he played the tow
route ah a loser I was always like he
can get like consonants where there's
nothing like he can make a one syllable
word into 20 okay it is a test for you
is your test for you if you shut your
eyes
yes okay is this the real voice of you
McCallum or is it somebody doing in
mechanik okay
Graham is there room for another mutant
on that sofa of yours what's real
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
594 to beat here we go here we go
Anthony Joshua until you know one oh no
I'm
[Applause]
I'm still going okay I tell you what was
yours eight eight P was three thousand
six and two wasn't what six seven two
six three two so if you don't beat back
thank you so tightly okay okay here we
go here we go this technique adieu the
world champion
it must have been mentions of a sequel
between it was 1982 wasn't it when it
came out so between then and now so what
why now why not before I guess because
Ryan wasn't available yes
well not for 30 years but they were
waiting for me to grow up but they
decided to have to go ahead anyway yeah
I came up with a good with the story I
read it and I thought it was awesome I
thought it was great and I as I read it
I read about the character that Ryan
play and I said and I with great
enthusiasm I called up the producers and
I said this is great I can't wait to get
robbed of and not a great park why don't
we see if we can get this is a great
park for Ryan Gosling
exiled Jim Duggan King Kong Bundy
scanned our Akbar's
hair Von Erichs he carry the cloth I got
a Hearst Coliseum in Shreveport for
pelting skandor akbar the bag of
tomatoes on the stand our Akbar was a
man dressed as a sheep that used to
throw fire yes man King Kong Bundy who
was like 484 pounds and remember there's
missing a word smarts unknown the green
faceless bit green mister they sound
really good good stuff and I'm John Cena
[Music]
[Applause]
the x-men set the games you play and
like the last it's the patient but in
this last x-men movie you did a new game
which just none of these games sounds
fun to me but you know II like them
well it's you kind of get sort of drawn
into them it's not that they're sort of
that enjoyable they're quite de
nerve-racking at times like that's
happening it just sounds like you're
just slapping the game is that you do a
shot don't you yeah and right after you
take the shot you get slapped in the
face yeah do you by the person the shot
they drink it and then you slap them
talking everyone's yeah no no it's just
you just deport each and you both have
one you both get here yeah lead to
employment for me which is good how did
this happen we would all maybe that part
of you're in San Diego at comic-con
didn't you knock someone out there again
particular we've got rivals in your
careers or not
no only recently I've never thought of
having rivals everyone gets on with what
they can do and there's plenty of room
for everybody but sometimes I think I am
Patrick Stewart except that he's
Yorkshire I'm sorry about that but you
are yes I'm from Lancashire but
interests are the same and as far as the
careers concert' which we started with
the RSC we wanted to draw shapes become
they want to do shapes we wanted to be
taken seriously as actors but given the
chance of another sort of work I've very
popular sort of work of course we let
that in Bolivar like that we'd been
asked laps or in your case asked back
again wasn't born in Wales lived in San
Francisco but I did a lot of my growing
up there so yeah I don't know I don't
think you gave me a big speech like this
is my land I said
a friend a friend transfer I was
beautiful beautiful you know
mountainside and lushness and and we
shot in this beautiful place called
Kualoa ranch where jurassic park the
original dress part was shot and the
ones after that as well and it was just
amazing but you didn't like it he hated
it no this is the problem I didn't I
didn't like it at all I mean outside of
the the spiritual ground said she took
me to and that's
the stories basically spider-man trying
to take a break he's trying to hang up
the spider-man suit and escape the
responsibilities of being a superhero
but what he learns throughout the course
of the film is that that responsibility
isn't something you can run away from
and that's when we team up and we sort
of become best buds on an off-screen
[Laughter]
okay turn it up
good to see the mood Ken Brown is going
to give us a little bit of form before
we do this if you do your face off to
your face come on come on okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
mangle hims a Korea the Korea because he
sometimes delivers unless he gets stuck
in traffic
it is Greg
[Applause]
[Music]
you know first let's have you I thought
that was gonna be heavier okay okay you
go first
mind the cameras here we go
so golf Oh
[Applause]
you go now you go now
hey Oh God
the corral
[Music]